on every pass i mean that's the thing
you know the word plaster is the word
that a lot of us use as coaches when the
quarterback starts scrambling uh our
d-line has to get them but we have to
plaster to our coverage for seven eight
nine ten seconds sometimes and some of
those past breakups were exceptional
efforts to hold on to their coverage as
long as they did
and it's a credit to jim o'neill and
paul gunther and certainly our players
for buying into that and getting that
done
john gruden coached the raiders after
the 40-32 victory over the chiefs in
kansas city signature win for gruden and
his return to coaching the first huge
win for the las vegas raiders and uh we
took a closer look at this one chris and
you know it was amazing
24 24 at the half yep and then the
entire third quarter not a single point
was scored and more importantly at the
end of the day it was eight points in
the second half for the chiefs only
eight points after 24 in the first half
what was the key
to the raiders
shutting down that chief's offense in
the final two quarters i i think the big
thing is halfway through the second
quarter and i kind of discussed this on
you know the the podcast yesterday
because i'm ron jaworski and i watched
the film and did all that but
the thing that jumped out to me more
than anything is they stopped blitzing
there was a point in the second quarter
where the chiefs had like a deep cross
to sami watkins versus the blitz and
they never blitzed again until fourth
and five late in the game and i think
that's the was the right call you know
mahomes is in that area where i you know
blitzing him is not a good thing
especially consistently you know like
john gruden just says he'll float around
back there and even though if you have a
free guy he'll float away from that free
guy and buy just enough time to where
all right yeah well your you know your
coverage is compromised downfield i'm
gonna make the right throw or i'm gonna
make that blitzer miss and now by a lot
of time and i don't care who you got
back there you can't plaster the
receivers that long they went into more
of the new england approach what we saw
on monday night last week was rush three
rush four have somebody spying mahomes a
little bit and they went in to get all
our guys downfield and back downfield
and cover them that way and that is
really what frustrated mahomes in kansas
city they never really my homes in the
second half never threw any passes
in rhythm and when i say that like you
know within the rhythm of the offense
how you were coached hey take a
three-step drop the first hitch throw
this guy then the second hitch throw to
this guy none of that happened in the
second half because they took away his
first read and he really ended up having
to play backyard football out of the
times and that's where i got to give the
raiders d uh a lot of credit there and
gunther paul gunther for making the the
correct uh
adjustment mahomes had been four for
four for 94 yards against the blitz he
was still pressured when they stopped
blitzing it gets back to what former
titans defensive coordinator dean p said
last year why bother to blitz him you're
not going to catch him and actually
right we saw him get hit by max crosby
and sacked and hit hard at it
the kind of thing where you never see it
we talked about that yesterday you see
him running around and he always knows
where everyone else is but you know what
if you give him too much to think about
down the field
if you flood sure the passing lanes and
the zones with an extra guy or two and
he's got to think a little bit more
maybe he loses sight of that sixth sense
as to who's going to hit him and maybe
that's the way you get him you keep him
so distracted on trying to find an open
guy
he can't do he can't do both he
eventually is so focused on finding an
open guy he loses track of who's chasing
him and you get him that way and you
know if you got to say and it was 47.1
percent of the dropbacks he was
pressured uh without the blitz
why blitz him yes right why why bother
flood lanes flood passing lanes and you
know again
andy reid i think and eric bienami they
kind of fell into the trap of like hey
we're just going to do what we do like
what we see them do every now and then
where you just go wait there's there's
no wrinkles to the offense or nothing
they're playing you for all these posts
and goes and deep crosses and they got
guys there that are covering you
man-to-man and then safety's in the
middle waiting for you like we saw in
some of the replays last week with the
patriots and the raiders to where
this is my big thing with the chiefs
again where are all those cool short
screens and things like that we saw in
the ravens game see to me that is the
big thing with the the chiefs they got
to have that part of the offense they
all those cool plays we see in the red
zone right tyree kill and nicole hardman
that to me
why don't we see that more in the middle
of the field because i think this is the
way like what we're talking about teams
are i think are going to start dabbling
in this this is two weeks in a row we've
seen two teams slow
the chiefs down with the
we're only going to rush four or we're
going to rush three and have somebody
there kind of spying mahomes like you
said and now he's buying time he's
looking down field trying to evaluate it
but he's also looking at the spy because
he's going wait i can't run he's kind of
there and he might lose track of a max
crosby or behind him or something like
that so
that to me is where the chiefs have to
you know
make the next move in the chess match
here is to have those type of things
start making teams
uh guard them horizontally a little bit
to where they have to come up more and
then you'll start to be able to go back
down vertical again and hit them that
way and that was something that just
jumped out to me about the chief's
approach it's a little bit of like this
is what we do we'll find and make a play
and do that and just it's hard to make
it work all the time that way
after the game i i spoke with raider
safety jeff heath who had an
interception of mahomes in the game in a
key moment and uh
here's a little bit of what heath had to
say on how they managed to keep the
chiefs in check
i think you got to uh you know give a
lot of credit to our coaching staff
i think they came up with a really good
plan to defend what what kansas city
does best and you know what man at the
end of the day it's just a football team
full of guys just like we are and they
can be beat now on any day and we knew
we were gonna have to you know bring our
a game and we knew it was gonna be a
we was gonna be a fight you know our
goal was really just you know once he
gets out of the pocket we had the
plaster we knew there's gonna be a lot
of long downs we knew where they like to
get some of their sas players and how
they like to use them so we had a plan
for that i'm not gonna be used to it
because we might use that
yeah they they have a sunday night
football date with kansas city chiefs in
las vegas coming up and uh you don't
want to go too far
into what you plan to do but it was
33-24 when heath intercepted the pass
took it all the way to the two two plays
later 40-24 and for all intents and
purposes at that point the game was over
uh
you know flipping around to the offense
because you know this is a big part of
dealing with the chiefs
you've got
to outscore them because it isn't
something
we're getting ready to hand out the
defense of the weak trophy to the
raiders and the chief still scored 32
points yeah well that's right i know you
know but but you have to be able to you
know they're going to score you just
have to be able to score more than them
and keep them from just having that kind
of
40.45.50 point explosion yeah well we
haven't seen uh i mean we haven't seen
the chiefs really lose games like this
you know like we talked a little
yesterday it's rare that they get into
the 30s and they lose a game like like
we saw uh definitely and again we talked
about the raiders defense the last thing
i'll say about the raiders divas that i
didn't hit on is just they changed up
coverages like no blitzing and never ran
the same coverage twice in a row they
never gotten a rhythm offensively
because of that now on the other side of
the ball yeah john gruden he deserves a
lot of credit for what he did i mean it
was like the best of both worlds it was
wait we got big plays to score points
like you're saying but yet
i didn't overdo it and i really stayed
patient with the run to keep that freak
of nature number 15 over on the bench
for a pretty good amount of time as well
so that to me was really one of the
great things when henry ruggs is in the
on the field and healthy you could see
he's a game changer he changes the way
their whole offense looks everybody else
is more open because of henry ruggs he's
like a tyree kill he's damn scary so i
can see why they love him and that
they're a different looking offense but
gruden's ability i thought to
not get overly infatuated with oh my
gosh the chiefs are lying crowding the
line of scrimmage and let's just go
bombs away
i think he did a great job of reigning
himself in and going wait in the bombs
away contest we're not going to win but
if i can kind of control the physicality
of the game
and then an occasional bomb
i might be able to win the football game
and to me that's where he was really
great the chiefs called the raiders
bluffs on some big situations where they
said i don't think you'll throw it
downfield i don't think derek carr will
do it we're gonna stop the run on third
and two or we're gonna stop the real
short raiders-like pass
and that's when we saw rugs deep down
the middle bam touchdown and they they
called the chiefs bluff back on them and
said oh yeah you want to play that okay
well we got something for you and they
capitalized a few times
yeah it was a 46-yarder to rugs early a
59-yard touchdown to nelson aguilar who
has really stepped up for the raiders it
helps to have a guy on the other side
that they're paying a lot of attention
to the 72-yard bomb to rugs and one
thing that stood out to me
derek carr threw an ugly interception in
the first quarter he was trying to get
the ball to darren waller right it was
one of those do you think you play for
the chiefs type throws and and that
didn't mess him up he wasn't deterred he
didn't he didn't stop you know whatever
they said to him on the sideline got him
right back into the frame of mind he
needed to be in and i was impressed by
that yeah because you know if you are
going to take chances down the field you
can't and that's one of the things you
always say you can't be worried about
the bad thing that may happen you've
just got to do it right and you can't
you can't dwell on the mistakes because
they're going to happen i mean the
bottom line is it didn't matter at the
end of the day but it's the kind of
thing that could have screwed him up and
i got to give him and the coaching staff
definitely credit for not letting that
happen you're right and and and and
really to to what you're saying and to
prove the point of why you got to keep
doing it because of how the game
you know played out look they didn't shy
away from it he didn't shy away from it
he kept attacking and you're right the
fact that he was able to block that out
that interception and still you know not
be bothered by it and pulled the trigger
on some other big plays as far as down
the field uh that that was big time and
that's hey the raiders can really put
you in a bind they really can it's one
of the best offensive lines in the game
and they can bludgeon you up front and
control the game with that and then when
rugs is in the lineup
man it's kind of a little bit of a pick
your poison aspect there to where i
don't think the chiefs will be able to
play defense the way they played this
pass game the next time they play the
raiders they won't not this oh we're
going to be aggressive get in your face
we're not going to let you run the ball
and we don't think you'll hit big plays
down the field that that'll have to
change i think that's been proven there
uh but derek carr yeah really good job
by him and and like i said john gruden
really great job of big time play calls
and big moments but staying patient with
the run too even though it wasn't always
pretty that way all day long
and how about devonta booker i mean josh
jacobs averaged 3.3 yards per carry on
23 attempts for 77. he was the leading
rusher of the day and had a couple of
touchdowns devonte booker had seven
carries for 62 yards 8.9 yards per
attempt he had one long run yeah i mean
this guy i forgot he was even still in
the league i remember he was drafted by
the broncos or a high hopes for him it
never worked out but to have that
one-two punch and that like you said
pick your poison if they can diversify
the offense and chris the other thing
too and we always say this about the
chiefs you can't settle for field goals
because you know they're going to get
their touchdown right and there was a
fourth and one
in the second quarter where
it was easy chip shot field goal range
and the raiders screw it we're going for
it right and they ended up capping that
drive with a touchdown pass and that's
what you have to do against the chiefs
you have to get your touchdowns you
can't settle for field goals and then i
also think a key moment
at the end of the half
when the chiefs had a touchdown called
back because of offensive pass
interference and they ended up getting
three on that drive anytime you can give
them four less points and you can get
four more for yourself it just it goes
into that that broader stew of they're
gonna score right but at the end of the
day we just need one more and the
raiders managed to pull it off and you
got to give them a ton of credit because
it looked like the chiefs
were especially at home this year when
you look at their schedule it looked
like they weren't going to lose a game
at arrowhead stadium no it just seems
like they kind of got that magic but
they got caught in something you've
always said where they kind of like
you know oh it's the raiders and we'll
just figure out how to make it happen
and we'll make a few plays and win the
football game and
the raiders are a little different
there's some talent
they got some corners and some guys in
the secondary that can run with some of
these receivers and then they got their
own group of receivers now too to where
yeah it's not just going to be dink and
dunk and smash mouth football with josh
jacobs that way so uh yeah this will
this is going to be interesting to see
the raiders going forward and if rugs
can stay healthy and you're i'm glad you
brought up gruden with the fourth and
one calls that was big time the fact
that they didn't settle for field goals
and scored touchdowns and just had that
right amount of aggressiveness you know
that you you look at them and you go oh
there's there's a lot to like about the
football team so we'll see where it goes
but i think they're like here to stay
right at least in my eyes just as far as
like a a team that i think is going to
be in this playoff conversation i think
i've seen enough from the raiders to go
i don't know if they make the playoffs
but they're going to be here in this
combo for for the the reindeer remainder
of the season
they got to build on what they did
they're off this week and then they have
the buccaneers on sunday night football
tom brady coming to las vegas which
should be interesting and oh by the way
you know the chiefs are a different team
they're a better team when their
opponent has the full focus the buffalo
bills on monday night will have the full
focus yeah they will kansas city chiefs
that will be a hell of a game and the
fact that the chiefs are feeling a
little you know feel a little nervous
now about what happened that's only
going to make them more locked in and
more determined to go to buffalo and
show what they can do
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports